your birthday with some exp were like yo
you posted Lana's birthday no no I know
his birthday was yesterday with the kobe
bryant thing you have to like hey
everyone stay happy birthday to Brian's
i'ma stay for money
yeah and I'll taste it for money I
thought about that too cuz I had three
bombers in in my weekend this is so
[ __ ] weird
so the day before my birthday I'm sorry
it was the day of my birthday it was the
day in the morning of my birthday but
mmm two people I know who are one a 64
and the other 62 I know them well though
and I've known them many years and they
both call me to tell me that they have
cancer and I'm not kidding and one is a
very rare form of I don't know but but
one is no I think you might have met one
of them but but either both have fun
yeah and and and they're both full of
life and good people and I went mmm I
was like wow the one they're both
serious situations you know life it's
not a fight of your life yeah kind of
stuff and and it was really sobering and
then and then Kobe Bryant dies that was
a bummer I'm not a baseball guy I mean a
basketball guy but what really got me
was his daughter and then I find out a
whole family and then I find out three
other little girls and nine people and I
know therapy I know there are tragedies
in the world here a lot of tragedies in
the world because that's so close to
home because it just it just sucks it's
just a bummer the whole thing's a bummer
it's just such a bomb it was so mainly I
thought about I thought about Kobe's
wife and two daughters and he's got a
third as an infant but the two daughters
and they have to walk by their child's
room their sister's room their child's
room and that child's never gonna be in
that room moment and I think about that
cuz you and I have children you and I
have to show an animal we know how how
unbearable that is for them right I told
chin all I couldn't sleep last night
thinking about you know Kobe at 41 young
man has no life for any balls and you
know why he was flying a helicopter no
to spend more time with family he got a
health care because he wants in traffic
so he takes kids of school spend more
time with him sure so that's the
original reason you got the health times
daughter was 13 who was who was always
like I'm I'll represent yes
Paul she's a Jew she had the Mamba
mentality yeah so I can tell CH in this
I'm blows but I couldn't sleep last
night thing about just when that plane
you know they're in that fog and they
were trying to figure it out and right
before it hit the thing here pull up
pull up and I just you I didn't know
that yeah there's a video of this is a
while to talk there's there's there's
after the the investigation yeah so
there's deep fog and he got a special
clearance still fly so there's a deep
fog and in Calabasas aware Calabasas
where he was going you know they ran
into the mountain and I just picture you
know these these nine people I'm you
know I'm sure there was talking like you
I can't see I you know I bet they hear
pawpaw and they're just that you know
you know you might I bet his heart went
oh [ __ ] yeah and just that yeah ah yeah
yeah and I you know and I just think I
just I don't I can't get this picture on
mind him just one oh and then yeah yeah
I like to think that I think about and I
like to think it was quick like to think
that well I'm sure I'm sure he says that
I'm sure was I I just I think about the
phone call that his wife got and his
wife having to tell her kids and that's
the kind Evan and that family there
there was a family baseball coach from
Orange County with his his two daughters
as an homage to was he I'm sure
phenomenal coach and it was just such a
bummer man it's one of those heavy
bombers butts the heaviest I'm heating
I'm eating in a restaurant in a heavy
I'm eating in a Lebanese restaurants
place called playa Peter which is really
authentic Lebanese and the guy there who
cooks all the food by his hand he said
he said his daughter was killed to it I
mean oh you know cuz I have an 11 year
old I go oh no I look up and he said my
daughter's 13 and he went back to work
it was just these heavy there's nothing
to be said we just shake our heads hold
our heads down you know in in some ways
you go the day before this you would
have said the Bryant's are the luckiest
kids in the world
that's that household and everything
allowed and then then you go they're the
most unlucky and you know just shows how
fragile life is he I'm sure you woke up
that's when I was like pay tolls girl hi
babe
I'm gonna take Gigi to basketball and
then we should be back you know probably
I'm for 4:30 so make sure they have
these plans and then it's like yeah it's
over me yeah it's over play that video I
say each in a film described why has the
its and I I'm sure I've always been
flying all over the world
everybody's feel it but it's like you up
you can you can cut the sadness with a
knife in a layman when you get on the
trafficking everybody has it if
everybody well he was a Laker right 20
year after school activities all that
fun stuff even all weekends but then
traffic started get really really bad
right and I was sitting in traffic I
want them missing like a school play no
sitting in traffic and this thing just
came out and I had to figure out a way
rock is still trained and focus on the
craft but still not compromise families
underneath so that's when I looked into
helicopters gonna be able to get down
and back in 15 minutes and that's what
it started so my routine was always the
same weights earlier morning kids to
school fly down practice like crazy do
my extra work media everything I needed
to do fly back get back in carpool live
pick the kids up and my wife was like
listen I can pick them all oh my no no
no I want to do that because like yeah
road trip sometimes you're not you don't
see is where you know so like every
chance I get to see them to spend time
with them even if it's 20 minutes in
your car like I one day you have to
school I get that you and I live that
way I'll do whatever I can
I raced back to take them tennis or
whatever it is there's a reason I don't
work on Sundays there's a reason why I
won't do any shows at a certain time
there's a reason why I don't do that
many other podcast you know what you've
done with this I race home you know when
you know you you know and you you're a
parent and that this is all you've did
describe how much you love your kids
when my kids are watching TV i watch
their faces I don't watch the TV oh yeah
yeah you watch how excited okay oh yeah
so yeah man we should probably address
such um we should probably address
because we've been getting a lot of dm's
and stuff I think it's appropriate to
address and I don't like doing this cuz
I don't like giving it any time and I
don't like given at any
I don't like honoring it with any
attention but I do think it's it's it's
important to address someone who's in
our community that we know who's been on
this podcast
Ari Shaffir and what he said in his
video and his is the reason why I sent
him a text yeah I don't believe in
talking behind anybody's back because I
I got a lot of it I got a lot of I got a
lot of text from other comics before
like can you believe this please no but
are very close to him so man and a lot
of people in the business that were
really outraged so now when I saw it
instead of I didn't want to join the
meal a I I like to talk about if I'm
gonna talk about somebody I'm gonna tell
it to their face but no one talks [ __ ]
about them everyone just goes I can't
like you can't believe it something's
wrong what's going on here and and and I
said I sent him a long text about how I
just found it really offensive and I
regretted sending the text I even said
to him I go because we got into a little
bit yeah you did and I and I and I and I
realized I said I don't know you that
well
and I'm actually regretting I even set
the text in the first place what am i
doing why am I even - I am i what am i
scolding Ari what an energy why my I
can't why am i what am i doing like that
it's not my place to even say this to
Ari but I didn't want to talk behind his
back I want to talk to him but it is and
it isn't cuz you're cut you know you're
mentored older guy you've been around
the game longer than everybody so it's
like I I guess when I saw it just made
me sad then I like I don't I I just I
don't I don't get the humor in in any of
it I didn't like the whole the whole
shock see if Ari was if Ari was an
[ __ ] I wouldn't care and I'm gonna
say this to people that I don't know Ari
well but I know people know Ari very
well and and I'll say this about Ari and
and my experience up until now with art
has always been that he's actually a
very kind-hearted yeah very kind-hearted
human being who means everywhere and
everywhere all the best all he's been
nice doing that so for me I swear to God
and I think you know this is true when I
saw that and I was getting all those
texts I guess because I am older and I
shouldn't have done this I had this
instinct to be like hey bro you can't do
this yeah I think I don't want to see
him law in his mind I've earned that I
hope so
I touched some was like dude I can't
believe you did this this is
a joke to me and yeah I'll haven't learn
that but if you are fewer Rogen or
someone yeah his peers that's fine he's
never been yeah I don't felt
inappropriate but I felt like I
literally felt like his people were like
well this is it for him this is gonna be
like you know when you do something like
this getting sponsorship getting a
special that's very big mate just makes
it way harder it's already hard he'll if
he cares my instinct was to be like hey
this isn't who you are
at least I've never seen that but he's
done it before and I'm like an Audi well
we've had we had a discussion with
someone else you pose with him and he
goes well whenever someone dies it's
what he does I just went but why like
even creatively it's not that funny it's
not I think I'm sure there's a nice
group of fans I don't know if I'm no I'm
just saying that might be like oh yeah
they're like but you know you're not
gonna win doing like dude it's here's
what I here's like that yeah it's not
the way to go no it's just not it's not
cool ninny fast I think I think what
we're trying certain things go beyond
what's called they state they go beyond
there's something called common decency
and this this was against common decency
but but - it wasn't but mica but why do
it though is it to move tickets is it to
gain those that underbelly of rotten
fans who jump on board I don't but what
but why do it for to get attention maybe
an angle maybe why don't we do but even
but even his but the narrative of oh I'm
glad this rapist died hold on Ari
hold on you know he's always been nice
to me nothing but great to me so I'm not
going bad on alright what I'm saying is
I don't understand it because from from
his point of view the rape stuff the
allegations look into that man he didn't
he says he followed it really closely
cuz I did it though you did but she
didn't though no but yeah I'm I'm from
there I'm from there I'm from there I
know people who are around there I know
people who know that girl I don't I
don't have all the facts I don't hear a
lot of him I have he says she says right
which Ari does to any narrative that I
want paint I can Google on the internet
if I want to Google Brian counts an
[ __ ] I can find the narrative that's
gonna pay
that fine Joe Rogan's an extreme leftist
I can find that near death somewhere on
there I can get that confirmation on the
internet so if Ari was searching for
that you're gonna find it yeah but you
don't know the facts now I don't have
all the facts what I do know is what
know what the courtroom found we know
that yeah we know it settled out of
court
yeah and we know and we do know that
that young lady's history that was
proven after this and we do know account
upon account of personal people that
know Kobe Bryant says he's a great guy
we do know a guy who has access to the
women upon women that has no history of
rape before this we do know that so when
a man of this a unicorn amongst human
beings dies and he's a dad and what he
represents guys with his daughter yes
and you take the narrative to others to
go this rapist it's just like well hold
on dude why do you think nobody talks
about that rape case also if you cared
about that rapist when you heard about
that girl did you give her money where
were you but why now and you can't say I
looked into the case when this was not
this this was not this no that's think
what happened I think what's happen is
it he had an impulse he was because
Hollywood liberals who attack comedy and
try rooting for the Lakers more than
they dislike great there's a very clumsy
thing to say it's it's it's it's very
clumsy all of us go there that's such a
clumsy a weird thing to say and I and
and I will say this about him I was that
the only thing I will say that I heard
from a reliable source is that he didn't
know Kobe was on the chopper when he
wrote this with children he be I'm not
kidding I'm not I'm not I'm not I'm not
hey Brooke there's any double down well
hey double down been doing well what I'm
trying to say is how did you add that
text exchange yes I did and then and
then what I was that I think and it what
I want to say is this it doesn't matter
what I was gonna say it doesn't matter
it's still just a [ __ ] thing to do and
and seem so out of character for this
guy like it's so parties always been
he's always been nice to me he's always
always been great to me men are he has a
million reason I don't know him I don't
know him well enough but he never does
yeah he's always been great
so I went oh because I first got brought
to my attention from Rapoport yeah
reporting goes this is your [ __ ]
friend like we're cool now if you did it
a Rogen did it or you know D'Elia did it
that's a different argue
I don't yeah I don't know are you enough
to text them now
I saw and I don't know there I'm in no
position to tell ru what he can and
can't do yeah you know Ari's a grown-ass
man I just found it so ill in poor taste
bro it's beyond even there's common
decency it's poor taste willing to do
it's not it's like even the whole
there's no comedy in it there's no
commonality but there's also no like I
looked into the rape no you didn't know
no I just
it's harshly it's not only it's puzzling
and if it offended me and it actually
hurt my feelings to me I mean he said I
found it I found it it made me so angry
and it's why I sent that text I was
getting all the sanno because this is
not I can't I can't have it we can't
have it my thing is is like that's that
stuff exists I expect this out of like
those trolls like online makes the wrong
[ __ ] dude go Celtics it's like that
makes sense that make that's other right
you're looking for some sort of
attention you're not giving and you're a
loser and you're a troll and you're you
have an egg is your avatar that makes
sense or you're you're a private profile
I get that from from their Seidler
they're looking some way to get
attention yeah but with Ari I'm like it
just doesn't make sense yeah because no
one's gonna go oh dude did you see Ari
[ __ ] on Kobe Bryant the day he died I'm
buying a ticket to that show
yeah I just don't I mean if they did god
damn it man yeah
in a way it's like getting it's like
prized always been nice to me that's
what but it's but the problem is I think
what people are doing is with what
happens is you you you're profiting it's
profiting off of the death and tragedy
of of someone in a way it's trying to
jump on that either way I think it sucks
it's very puzzling I don't I don't I'm
gonna end it with this I don't need to
talk about it
or or to him or any of that anymore
that's all good I just wanted to say
that too you can see do it - yeah cuz we
got a lot of with this let's do it to
get a rise everyone cuz cuz then we're
given what I never did like any human
being if you ask somebody who did
something like this they maybe in a year
he won't he'll he might regret it maybe
he's done it before yeah I think he's
done a pros history
I really don't know he dies cuz I were
type again we're talking a mutual friend
he knows and very well goes he kind of
always does this I don't agree with it
but he can't always doesn't like a [ __ ]
dude yeah I'll tell you right now being
if you did this I don't know where your
next show is it you did this yeah seven
people show up to your show yeah yeah
but I would never do that I don't have
that in my in my body to do this yeah
it's it's it's a weird it's it's a weird
it's it's more of a [ __ ] you to the
world it whatever's going on with him
it's a it seems like an anger and a [ __ ]
you to the world that's what it is so I
think is account was a suspended no this
is from all a while back so I'm just
seeing what his history is like no I
guess it's just puzzle it's just we had
to it we had to address it because he
knows a lot of people are hitting us up
with this I had to address it I didn't
want to I guess that I stand by
everything I've said here I'd say right
to his [ __ ] face I'll always say it I
die I'm it's disappointing it's
offensive IIIi can't have it around me
no makes me sad and I just all this said
I have and will say to his face so I'm
not talking about my lovey I don't like
going bad on anybody who can't defend
themselves who's right here now I think
this is indefensible
if I saw my have nothing to say what are
we gonna talk about I but as far as this
like it's like I don't agree with you
mean I think it's super [ __ ] up okay
well I think you can I can make a joke
any time nothing's too soon all right
that's your prerogative that's fine it's
not a joke there's no joke I'm just
alright where's the comedy could you
find any comedy I've been doing how many
a long time you would know better than
me Brian I have no idea but that's what
I'm saying there's nothing to talk about
yeah I don't know I'm just running just
do it just hurts my feelings are he's
always been so kind to me and I see I'm
like oh well I can't
i what are we in what did he did he pull
it down tweet
I heard he tried to roasted on birds and
then there's a video that I think he's
got birds and they posted a video and
then I think the backlash was so bad you
took it down but then you know how you
know Twitter or dance cam what's it's
out its out do ya alright we've said
enough that's where we stand on it and
you know I have a question about that
you guys know him
kinda like you kind of know his history
right you don't own you got to realize
like and you speak for me cuz you're
here before this but when I got brought
in to like the group I met Brian I met
Chris I met Sasso Rogen Brian Sasso
D'Elia those were my guys I was never
like oh he was already in New York yeah
I know re through Rogen and then you
know then he's friends with Burt
everything I know about re-up and
everything I've seen with Ari
everything I've everything I've seen
every kind of station I've had with him
everything I've watched him do up until
this point has been positive I'll say
that's what's I don't know enough but
I've he's done that's what job I'm just
telling you the truth in your Lord I
don't [ __ ] him now when people he's done
shocked stuff like this before
well I don't really see I don't I don't
feel a lot of stuff but this this is a
this is seems to be a necklace I'm
asking do you think it's self sabotage
yes in no not with Ari
I think he'd I think this is this is
what he does huh it's good I guess
there's me a niche demo who are like oh
yeah do you know have no [ __ ] clue
what they're talking about who if you're
well those people do not come to my show
don't come to Brian show don't listen to
this show this ain't for you I'm not
about that man now I will tolerate any
of them no man it's a bum me out
me to a bum you buy you know I got
global perspective I know there's
tragedy everywhere and I know there are
bigger tragedies but that bum me out
it's fine it should that's crying this
morning I was crying this morning man
they're shown his daughter you know
Brennan you're an athlete
and I think you have a very intimate
understanding of what it took to become
him and how rare that dude is off that
and every new god I've no idea I don't
know well that's right and it's more
than just athleticism it's the ability
to manage excellence across your whole
life this is what we all try to do we
all try to be we all try to self perfect
and when you see somebody who's able to
do it on a level not just athletically
socially but as a family dude and you
see that you you are reverential when I
I saw him one time never met her but I
saw him I was just and I was looking at
him I go well that's he's the best he's
the best at what he does
anytime somebody like that is lost at 41
when they have a lot more work to do it
sucks
it's a [ __ ] bummer and to be mocked
[ __ ] off all right this is such a shame
man yeah and and and again let's not the
family the other family oh the other
family other people died they're
horrible the other thing just is
terrible the other thing too is uh you
know there's a very famous race British
racecar driver who's like a billionaire
who got around helicopter and him and
his family died in the same way yeah in
a helicopter a few years ago
my dad who's we hire let me bring up Jen
I call my dad as a pilot and he looks at
these stats all time
I know our helicopters dangerous and he
said no he said people live in
helicopters they live in them you know
yeah but the thing is when you crash
it's it's not it's not if your crash
ain't no you're gonna yeah that's right
oh that's the guy yeah we talked about
this guy before just on about how he
looked and then we saw this crash - yeah
so was with this daughter yeah very
famous yeah yeah Jesus adds we're all
going yeah I think that's the biggest
thing like you know you just you realize
like [ __ ] man you never know
know right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch
your tongue Oh what's gonna happen what
are you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]